Yasmine Mehdi.
- Ce sont des travailleurs quiss
mais qui se fondent souvent dans
le paysage urbain.
Voià que ces livreurs ne veulent
plus rester dans l'omb..
- Ça commence.
- C'est le cas de Brice Sopher,
qui travaille pour Gig Workers
United,  s syndicat de livreurs
récemment  constitué à Toronto.
- Normalement, je sors quatre
ou cinq jours par semaine.
- DJ de profession, Brice a
commencé à faire des livraisons
à vélo en 2015. Depuis la
pandémie, c'est devenu sa
principale source de revenu.
BRICE SOPHERS, vice-président
Gig Workers United- On veut être
des employés, parce que
ces compagnies, elles ont le
contrôle complet sur la façon
dont on travaille.
- Le travail est éreintant et
cococonditions, difficiles.
Pas de sécurité d'emploi, de
salaire minimum ou d'avantages
sociaux, car les livreurs comme
lui sont considérés comme
travailleurs autonomes et non
comme des employés.
À cela s'ajoute le fait que
beaucoup de ces livreurs sont
de nouveauvavavavants, qui
n'ont pas nécessairement accès
à d'autres types d'emploi.
C'est le cas de Saurabh Sharma,
qui est récemment arrivé d'Inde.
Avocat de formation, il doit
se tourner vers Uber pour payer
ses factures en attendant que
ses diplômes soient reconnus
au Canada.
"Je dirais que 80 % des
personnes qui ont cet emploi
sont de nouveaux arrivants",
affirme le livreur, qui voudrait
que le gouvernement protège
mieux les travailleurs comme
lui.
Pendant la pandémie,
le gouvernement Ford a souvent
so'a'a'a'a'apport de ces
travailleurs.
Et le ministre ontarien du
Pendant la pandémie,
le gouvernement Ford a souvent
souligné l'apport de ces
travailleurs.Et le ministre ontu
Travail répète qu'une réforme
des lois encadrant le travail
précaire sera bientôt présentée.
Devant cette main tendue,
Brice Sopher reste méfiant et
s'inquiète qu'un nouveau cadre
législatif ne soit à l'avantage
des multinationales ererererer.
- Il faut être réaliste que
beaucoup de politiciens,
beaucoup de gens dans le
gouvernement, leurs campagnes
sont supportées par les gens
avec de l'argent.
- L'an dernier, ces compagnies
ont remporté une victoire légale
de taille en Californie,
qui a cimenté le statut de
travailleurs autonomes de leurs
livreurs.
Ce syndicaliste américain
rappelle qu'Uber a dépensé des
millions en lobbyi
parvenir à cette fin et croit
que l'entreprise utilise les
même tactiques au nord de la
frontière.
Au Canada, Uber ne cache pas
ses efforts de lobbying.
L'entrepttttttttttttttre de
l'avant un modèle hybride où ses
travailleurs ne seraient pas
reconnus comme des employés,
mais obtiendraient des
avantanges sociaux à la pièce.
JONATHAN HAMEL, gestionnaire des
affaires publiques Québec, Uber
- On créerait un fonds qui
serait géré par l'industrie et
les travailleurs, eux autres,
pourraient utiliser ce fonds
d'avantages sociaux comme ils le
souhai
- Entre 2005 et 2016, la
proportion de de travailleurs àe
de 5,5 % à 8,2 %.
Brice Sopher croit que ce
chiffre continuera d'augmenter,
d'où l'importance pour ces
travailleurs de se mobiliser.
- Pourquoi est-ce que je ne
pourrais pas gagner ma vie à
faire ce travail? Tout le monde
devrait avoir droit à la
dignité.
- Travailler dans la dignité,
c'est le combat que Brice Sophee
continuer la lutte, qu'importe
les obstacles sur son chemin.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio